but you sell the steroids that's how
much that's how you make the real money
in the fitness game
is that true
[Music]
Cali muscle everybody know Cali yeah
remember the videos where he would sit
in a prison cell and he would make like
this is what I you eat to get big yeah
he'd do like Ramen and tuna and then
tuna mix it up it kind of looked good
though you said What ginger bang noodles
specifically good night girls yeah way
better than Top Ramen are those
available in jail I love topics yeah
yeah it's specific for that 11 grams of
protein brother so this uh chicken soup
has now come out and he said he's not
scared actually to lift weights in
general after suffering a horror heart
attack and a near-death experience I
think when you see his [__] dumbbells
he almost faints
oh [__] he blames the weights instead of
the steroids
[Laughter]
I don't know if he blamed him he
probably just scared my mother doctor
told him oh he's scared of the weights
instead of scared of the steroids no man
okay muscles Natty bro he's off he's off
[__] now I know did he did he shrink he
got a little smaller he's still jacked
but he's definitely he's way smaller
than it was before but he's still big
because he was like cartoonish yeah but
what does he do like push-ups now like
does he still work he's down with the
bar is he like completely just not even
doing anything I'm sure he still works
out a little but he just opened up
recently about the advice he wished he
could give his younger self uh after
suffering the the hardest what's the
advice you do like a Rebrand he just
said he believed that he had ignored a
lot of warnings in the build up to his
heart attack and since he's been
advising others not to do what he did
and failed uh and failed to pay
attention to the signs what would be the
signs he's just saying don't do steroids
without saying it he's saying like don't
do steroids I did them but he doesn't
want to say that what what is the thing
about uh a lot of bodybuilders that have
heart issues is it a specific steroid
that causes that or not just that thing
I talked about earlier with like the
left ventricular hypertrophy and that's
not good for health happens and then
cholesterol and I'll think it plugs it
up or yeah I mean cholesterol related
issues as well can really [__] with you
but um
for him he had a I'm sure he had like
hospital visits where they were like hey
get off of steroids uh he's probably
like what's steroids
probably all kinds of [__] like the
warning signs like oh I had similar
signs to a stroke or a heart attack
before and I just didn't come off I was
like [__] it I'm Immortal that's all
these guys get you know what I mean yeah
so fit looking guys can still have high
cholesterol oh absolutely because of the
stuff I mean the highest thing is
genetics oh he said uh cholesterol was
from diet yeah he had or Cheerios um he
had to undergo life-saving surgery and
since then he's been promoting a
healthier lifestyle which is further
removed from the pressures some
bodybuilders face to bulk up as much as
possible in particular he has warned
people to stay well away from steroids
and said he wished he could give his
younger self that same advice what do
you think about like that pressure that
because we kind of touched about that
last time right like again if you you
want to be like a bodybuilder or
something like that or any sport and
then you're out there you're trying to
be all natural and all the other guys
who are like getting these bigger
contracts or winning the competition or
whatever are on these things then you
maybe feel that pressure
you definitely can I think uh the cool
thing about social media now is that
you're making more money doing those
types of things anyway so uh it was
before YouTube the just actors were
making shitloads of money right just
actors and singers and people like that
and now you guys have made a shitload of
money just by sitting here and talking
as a group of friends
so you don't have to like fight to be
into you don't gotta fight to be like oh
I want to be an actor now in this movie
and I got to get this contract and it's
going to make me whatever amount of
money but it's like same thing with
bodybuilding and fitness and all that
you can build a huge brand like even I
mean Barbara Brigade right like blew the
way the [__] up
um never heard of it be natural be a
good coach it's for company give really
good advice for training and dieting and
you can make more money than any lunk
head on steroids who's trying to compete
for a bodybuilding title you don't make
money
bodybuilding it's not a thing you can
make money from some sponsorships which
even then those contracts are [__]
wish wash now they're just like oh we'll
give you two grand a month or something
like that because the tick tocker over
there who has eight million followers is
making most of their money anyway so
it's doing I agree like doing steroids
is it's not something you have to do
um
big reason why I do it so I could go
through that process and be like hey
this is exactly what you're going to
experience it's probably not worth it
for most people if you want to actually
healthy lifestyle this is how you can do
it ashwagandha ashwagandha
I don't like it when people phrase it
that way where it's like the pressures
of whatever I don't know whatever
because it's like you embark on your own
journey and you make your own decisions
like having a like well it's because you
know what the bodybuilding is pressure I
have to take it it's like no dude like
just admit that you wanted to try it and
then now you regret it and you can
totally say that and it feels way more
honest and vulnerable and it actually
teaches a good lesson if it is his his
like goal to teach a lesson than to say
oh man it's the society is pressures
because then now you take the blame off
yourself there are there are Industries
though like where well obviously in the
entertainment industry too right there's
definitely times where I know like um
you know female homies that like uh if
they want to be repped by this you know
High fashion brand or campaign or
whatever like maybe they gotta drop some
weight you know what I'm saying because
they have to look at certain things but
if they drop the weight it should be on
them I want to drop the weight so that I
can get this thing versus the brand made
me drop weight you know what I mean like
technically true yeah it's just the way
that you because she had a goal to be in
that industry versus she could have been
like I'm against that [__] this [__] I'm
gonna make my own path especially with
someone like like him like perfect
example of somebody with phenomenal
genetics he would have been jacked as
[__] no matter what
um he wanted to do the steroids to get
even bigger because that was something
internal that had nothing to do with the
popularity of the fame he got all that
[__] anyway he has a personality he's
literally just a personality on the
internet and he had that already he was
like super loud and obnoxious and people
[__] loved it because he's hilarious
at some points in time and that would
have been him no matter what would he
have had like less followers who [__]
knows maybe maybe not maybe he would
have really [__] rode into the
natural thing like the liver King dude
then people would have been in even more
respect like oh that's what's up it was
just Top Ramen and tuna that's that's
cool because he would never admit it
yeah he would never like he'd always
Dodge that question be like no I'm not
yeah because with Cali muscle I think
people like him because of his
personality he's funny yeah he's funnier
dude and he makes Fitness Fun he can
talk about anything and you're like I'm
in I'm watching like one of the most
[__] crazy things that I actually
tried was because of him because he was
saying like in prison you can't get
pre-workout so he used to make this make
this thing called hyphy Mud and it was
and he would take and like uh like two
of coffee ground coffee powder and then
I remember like I was like oh [__] that
looks [__] crazy and I would make my
own hyphy mud and drink it at home today
was it the diarrhea huh no it tastes I
mean it kind of tastes good actually
they make that [__] now yeah like
Coca-Cola does
yeah like stuff
they stole that [__] from them [__] oh
it was like 2012 2013 I was like making
my own hyphy mud at home just [__]
around dude High people I watched this
uh name Fitness documentary it's a
pretty popular one called Pain and Gain
and then um good documentary Mark
Wahlberg yeah and I realized that all
the money is in selling the steroids so
you're advertising as the buff guy but
you sell the steroids that's how much
that's how you make the real money in
the fitness game
is that true
yeah
Pain and Gain and they told me that so
no pain again is about two guys that
tried to do that at a really high level
and they got caught yeah they went to
prison
um but no it's not where the money is at
all oh you don't you don't get caught
doing that [__] either so is the money
in the the merch because gym shark you
know he's oh yeah British youngest
billionaire really but he takes zero
steroids you can tell he's a thick throw
it's shout outs to you Ben Francis you
could tell because he's weak as [__] huh
he looks slim the money isn't where you
put your effort like like I said social
media is dope as [__] because it can
give all these kids opportunities to
just uh
go have their own personalities and try
to make something out of it I think
wanting to be an influencer is the
dumbest [__] in the world um I think you
guys should just go to school and
actually provide for society go get a
job at Tesla please
um but everyone wants lazy money though
it's crazy man I hate it it's like can I
just make money from people liking me
like that's literally what it is it's
literally what they want to do yeah and
I mean like you know more power to you
create a brand creative personality
whatever you're doing if you blow up you
blow up hell yeah that's what's up maybe
you can you know as you go through that
process learn a bunch about yourself in
the world and try to make it better but
you know don't try to be an influencer
just because you think it's cool and
don't take steroids to do that but what
if ridiculous they're just stupid and
that's the best that's the best shot
they're dumb and they're born with a
pretty face it's called only fans
but what if oh yeah yeah they have that
but what if but what if you're also you
got a little bit of morals so it's like
I'm gonna be a fitness influencer cool
look at my butt cheeks yeah but it's for
Fitness reasons yeah exactly so it looks
like I'm wearing nothing reassess your
morals I'm thankful for some of them
which ones yeah is this video over we
got a long way to go
[Music]